you know I used to think that I know it
all but all I did was walk into my own
arrogant wall I traded good character
for pride
and Truth was lost on the other side
[Music]
I wanted to live selfishly for the world
with all its sin that's what I thought
would make me successful and win
but he did not and I slowly felt my
inner man rot
I chased off their money alcohol and
girls of all my fleshly might why not I
was young and wanted to feel the life of
the night
they say that money makes the world go
round and round but they don't tell you
that evil lurks in the background
you see I thought I was invincible the
master of my own life
but when truth set me free
I realized I was just another low life
one day I suddenly got a phone call that
would forever Change Me A New Path that
would finally make me free but came at a
great cost as you'd usually does to
those who are lost
my father's voice came trembling through
the phone with pain telling me I need to
come home with the airplane you see my
second brother Etienne is about to die
and he asked me to come and say goodbye
I flew back home finding myself next to
him on the hospital bed
I see my brother
lifeless
he's dead
why God why did you take another brother
from me
this can't be real
please make him alive again
that was my plea
and suddenly God spoke directly to my
soul
the saying I was on a dangerous role
Daniel your brother is saved here with
me
but if you died in hell you would be
this is your wake-up call to look the
truth of life in the eye and decide
where you want to end up when you die he
showed me the truth of death and life
and urged me to take a deeper breath
I took your brother because he was ready
and deep down you know that already
stop running away from me and make your
choice the devil or me and say it with
your voice
Daniel you're arrogant and wasting your
short life you never even think about
the afterlife
he called me out for my arrogance and
showed me the lack of my significance I
have always been there protecting you
and your small brain does not even have
a clue with his loving voice I began to
see
the truth that had always been around me
even though you know for a fact I am
real growing up the way you did with
your father full of spiritual Zeal you
know I am your creator who love you and
you know that's true it's time what do
you say you've been walking in the dark
for too long as a stray
[Music]
come home to me so I can make you whole
save your Eternal Soul
all right okay God but I don't want a
man-made religion I want you
I can now feel your love and I just want
to be close to you like glue
please change me even if you have to use
the rod please forgive me for all my
sins because I've been using them like
skins I can see the evil within me and
only with you can I be truly free
that is the day my whole life Changed by
God it was arranged
he made me a new creation so that I can
be saved from Damnation
and I will see my brothers again from
Heaven that is only some of what I will
gain you see I'm now a new creation
that's free because of his spirit that
is within me he freed me from sin death
and pain and now I'm living a life
that's truly sane
[Applause]
I was blind but now I see thank you God
for saving me and making me the person
that I was always meant to be